high-speed internet supersonic jets
instant coffee instant noodles
would you believe our world is slowing
down they say time flies when you're
having fun but over the past 100 years
including the 20s the 60s and the 80s
our days have actually gotten longer
before you say you're telling me let's
just clarify the average length of a day
has only increased by 1.7 milliseconds
but what if you could get more out of
your day what if a great night never had
to end what if one day lasted an entire
year and in that time you could walk
around the whole earth this is what if
and here's what would happen if the
earth were to suddenly stop spinning the
Earth rotates at an average speed of
1,000 miles per hour giving us night and
day while harnessing wind tides and
temperature so what would happen if
these revolutions that are so vital to
our existence were to suddenly stop
imagine owning the fastest sexiest
sports car in the world pretty nice huh
the open road calls there's no traffic
in sight and no Highway Patrol officers
either so you decide to test its top
speed driving at 1,000 miles per hour
out of nowhere an obstacle you hit the
brakes your car stops suddenly but you
don't that's what would happen at the
moment the earth stops spinning
everything that isn't safely secured or
tied down will be suddenly sent flying
eastward at 1,000 miles per hour
humans cars even pigs the fastest wind
ever recorded was 253 miles per hour in
this scenario were talking about winds
four times as strong feeling similar to
an atomic blast in less than a minute
towering tsunamis would sweep more than
17 miles inland all the water from the
world's oceans would surge towards the
poles
since the globe bulges at the equator
the north and south pole are closer to
the center of the earth and therefore
have a stronger gravitational pull the
seven seas would turn into two forming
one mega ocean in the north
and another in the South Canada most of
Europe and Russia would be completely
submerged Boston Chicago and Seattle
would also be underwater along with
parts of Argentina Chile and New Zealand
the oceanic displacement would form a
massive supercontinent along the equator
wrapping around the entire earth while
this might make it easier for any
surviving humans to work together
there'd be little anyone could do to
improve their lot resources would be
scarce the world would experience wide
scale drought and most species would be
endangered if not already extinct
agriculture would be nearly impossible
to maintain since a full day would now
last an entire year in other words you'd
see the Sun for six straight months and
spend the other half of the year in
darkness this would also inhibit the
natural transition between seasons the
final fatal consequence would be the
loss of our magnetic field aside from
giving us a sense of direction Earth's
magnetic field ensures our survival by
deflecting solar wind which would
otherwise rip through our ozone layer
and blast us with harmful radiation
deadly cosmic rays would effectively
kill all living things on the planet and
over time the world as we know it would
turn into Mars as we know it wait a
minute
are we trying to travel to Mars and
possibly live on it our Mars and Earth
just gonna switch places is this what it
means to come full circle even if we
don't come to a screeching stop the
world will one day stop spinning in
about eighteen point five billion years
so for now enjoy the time you have seize
the day and make every night great
[Music]
[Music]